WEIRD INDIE GAMES
NOW, IF YOU'RE A GAMER BUT YOU
DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT BIG
CONSOLE BY BUYING THE LATEST
MADDEN OR HALO, THERE'S
TONS OF WEIRD UNIQUE INDIE
GAMES MADE BY DEDICATED
ARTISANS WHO HAVE PASSION AND
DEDICATION AND TONS AND TONS OF
MARIJUANA. SO CONTESTANTS, I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU
TWO DESCRIPTIONS AND WHICH
IS THE ACTUAL GAME.
>> FIRST ONE, MOUNT YOUR FRIENDS
GRUNTING MUSCELMEN WITH
HUGE PENISES DOG PILE ON A GOAT
OR SWORD COLLECTOR, YOU PLAY
AS A HEAVY METAL FAN WHO
COLLECTS SWORDS EVEN THOUGH YOUR
GIRLFRIEND TELLS YOU IT IS A
WASTE OF MONEY.
>> THE REAL SHOW IS MOUNT YOUR
FRIEND.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
>> OH
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THE PENIS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> GOT TO BE HONEST, I KIND
OF WANT TO PLAY THAT.
>> THAT POOR SHEEP.
>> HE'S HAVING A GOOD TIME,
HE'S MEDITATING.
>> THOSE ARE NOT REAL
FRIENDS.
>> ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
A RUSSIAN GAME WHERE YOU
PLAY A DUMPSTER BABY WHO
STEALS VODKA FOR PROSTITUTES.
>> OR HURRY! ENSCONCE THE
WOMEN! AN ITALIAN GAME
WHERE YOU MUST HIDE THE
PRIME MINISTER'S MISTRESSES
FROM THE PAPARAZZI. ANDY DALY.
>> IT'S GOT TO BE DIMITROVA
STREET BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH
THAT IS A BIG WORD NONE OF
THESE PEOPLE KNOW ENSCONCE.
LET'S FIND OUT.
>> DRIMITROVA STREET.
(APPLAUSE)
>> THAT IS LITERALLY THE
MOST HORRIFYING THING I
THINK I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> I NOW HAVE A GREAT RESPECT
FOR MAINSTREAM VIDEO GAMES.
>> THE LAST ONE.
OLD YELLER SIMULATOR 3,000,
YOUR BELOVED DOG HAS RABIES AND
YOU PUT THEM DOWN WITH A
GRENADE LAUNCHER, OR BABY MAKER
EXTREME, A SHOOTER WHERE
PREGNANT WOMEN ROCKET BABIES
OUT OF THEIR VAGINAS. YES, BUSY.
>> I'M SOMEWHAT OF A BABY
MAKER EXTREME SO I WILL GO
WITH THAT ONE.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
>> BABY MAKER EXTREME.
>> YEAH!
>> THAT IS ALMOST EXACTLY
NOT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
I GAVE BIRTH.
>> BECAUSE I ALWAYS WONDER
WAD ANGRY BIRDS WOULD BE
LIKE WITH FETUSES.